Thank you. I'm going to talk a little bit about transplant and it's appropriate. We are on the end. We had been on the end for a long time. End of the patients, end of the journey, end of everything. Only what I would say, I was recently in China. We in Baylor had CD7 CAR-T and I think they did 10 patients. We were so excited.
In China, at the same time, they did 450 CD7 CAR-T and conclusion was you still need a transplant.
So I think until we retire, we have enough business.
So let me give you a little bit about PTCI because whatever you do with the transplant, you'll be hitting some of these issues.
So PTCI, a relatively new kid in the block since early 2000.
There have been so many different studies very nicely outlined.
I'll give a little bit more perspective.
And probably two most important, two recent New England Journal of Medicine,
which really puts it in a lot of perspective as a standard of care.
Just to put it a quick summary, it is universal GVHD prophylaxis.
According to NNDP, approximately 70 to 80% of entire transplants are being done with PTCI.
It works across the HLA donor success, the graft sources, across conditioning regimens.
A few points to understand, relapse is not
increased with PTCI.
It is exactly the same, if not even a little bit better than no increase of PTLD.
There are new strategies that you can build up this transplant and stop immunosuppression early, because I think we are all learning.
The next setup is how do we bring something as X in the context of the transplant?
And it's most importantly, the transplants are being done around the world.
So same thing, what we talk about, the transplants are currently routinely done in entire, entire China.
It is done in the.
All far east, Latin America.
So this is something which works around the world.
Other things worth considering is that you have multiple donors to choose.
And we discuss, I'm not going to get into discussion.
So at this moment, every patient should have a donor.
There are variability of the donors depending on your center's preferences and your urgency for the patients.
Just few numbers to highlight for the haploidentical, more than 95% of entire transplants are done with PTCI.
These are all data on the mods.
I currently is around 70% of entire mods are done by repeat PTCI mismatch mods, probably around 90% are also being done with PTCI.
So it's becoming really a common prophylaxis that a majority of your patients might encounter.
So what are the current strategies for the PTCI further optimization?
The bigger question is what we just briefly discussed is the optimal dose of 50 times to the right dose.
And I'm going to touch.
A little bit about it, how we can address some of the toxicities and CRS with PTCI and bone and peripheral blood specifically, if you are hitting donor over 70 can be an issue.
It is not the same as a CAR-T, but there are issues with some CRS in all the patients.
If you are using a peripheral blood, other issue is most importantly, how we can combine PTCI with new agents, because we are also getting excited about some of the
the new agents which are coming through the portfolios.
So a few things, PTCI 100 versus 80, this was very old question specifically in the China because of LDH enzyme, which is started with PTCI.
There was a question, does this impact survival in the Asian population?
And based on this retrospective data and clinical trials from the from the Japanese group, there could be no difference.
So if you really want to cut and cut a little bit, which is for the TIE2, it seems there is very solid data.
The data from Japan, there is no major difference in outcome.
This is the data from combined study from French and Italian group against showing the dose.
If you want to cut 40 BID, there are no randomized trials.
It seems to be the survival is the same.
You might have actually a little bit less VK virus, but are the old centers comfortable?
And which patient do you want to cut?
It is up to the centers.
There is no real randomized studies to decide what is the better.
But this is the kind of where there is a solid retrospective institution data.
So the question is, can you even cut it further?
This is one of the hottest questions in the transplant field.
There are a few studies trying to cut PTCI going over up to the dose of 25.
You said the data from and from NCI Chris can actually a few differences.
This is this was done mostly with bone marrow graft and in context of serolimus prophylaxis, serolimus
works sometimes better than the TAC limus.
So you really need to be attuned.
What are you doing?
And this had been tested mostly in the younger patients.
Results looked pretty reasonable and pretty good for 25 based on the published data.
There is ongoing trials between between NCI and UPenn.
There will be paper coming soon with those of 25 PTCI.
So there will be a little bit more data for you who are interested.
It appears there might be a little bit more chronic GVHD, but this is something what we need to learn.
Early outcomes, what NCI group had reported, pretty good incidence of grade two and grade three and four GVHD.
So if you have a patient who really needs it, this is something to try.
But again, there are no real data to improve this in the peripheral blood.
And the majority of our grafts these days are in the peripheral blood.
Other interesting story, because as we are pushing the transplant beyond age 70 to the late 70s, little CRS.
Specifically, when you give a graft, you have these four days without immunosuppression can have prominent effects on all the patients.
And there was a very interesting study done by a group of Washu who basically integrated JAK inhibitor in context of PTCI,
which opens an entire new way where we might be going by adding JAK inhibitors.
They had very, very good data on this prevention, CRS, outcomes were pretty good.
But the only thing that was really interesting was that this drug was pulled out of the market because this was etacitinib.
It was pulled out because of inefficacy in other setting.
People are now trying to get the Ruxolitinib, something to be looking into it.
But I think we'll be seeing more and more of these agents coming in in the context of a post-graft immunosuppression.
Which leaves me now that something for you all to watch for, and there will be BMT CTN trials, there will be other trials and some of your institution.
The biggest question is currently how do we move haploid related,
unrelated to PTCI with other partners and JAK inhibitor is something which is happening earlier this on how we can bring this surgeon and why we should be doing this.
Because as we are hearing for last few days for our leukemia colleagues, there is a huge, huge interest to continue this maintenance post-transplant.
And the sooner we can have shortened immunosuppression, stop it earlier so we can give this additional agency, some of what we'll be doing, it probably will be focus of all of
our efforts in the next 10 years.
So I really don't have a right answer what is the partner X, very likely JAK inhibitor will be coming and it will be something we'll be having the two different roles,
prevention of CRS and prevention of GVHD.
And this is certainly where we are doing, I think 225, this is old slide.
We are all improved, we can transplant everybody, but best what we can do is the 40, 50% five-year survival.
So last 20 years, we can deliver this now to everybody.
But in the need, but how do we go to the higher numbers?
This is where we need to do a learn and PTSI, head expanded access, but we think it's also the platform to move this curve to the higher numbers and give better outcomes to our patients.
Thank you very much.